every single minute 24 people around the
world flee their homes because of
violence and natural disasters war or
human rights violations as a result
there are around 65 million people who
have currently been forcibly displaced
from their homes fifty percent are under
17 years old while seven percent are
unaccompanied minors but where do they
go while many have discussed the social
and political implications of these
moving groups we wanted to understand
how do you build a refugee camp refugee
camps exist around the world from
Azerbaijan to Thailand to one of the
largest camps to death located in
eastern Kenya which currently has two
hundred and forty six thousand people
living we decided to visit Leslie a
Greek island near Turkey which has been
an essential entry point to Europe for
refugees fleeing places like Syria and
Afghanistan and making the trip across
the Aegean Sea from Turkey to Greece the
capital of lesbos is MIT aleni
a surprisingly lively port city
considering its population size of
around 30,000 people but as the refugee
crisis began in 2015 it became one of
the spontaneous sites for those fleeing
war and persecution and a transit
refugee camp called Kara Tepe was set up
on the outskirts of the city which would
become a gold standard for refugee camps
currently it is housing at-risk
populations in the beginning Kara Taipei
was was just an olive grove no place to
shower no place to you the bathroom it
was complete chaos
at the peak of the refugee crisis
thousands of people were arriving daily
to this area they would stay for two to
three days and then continue their
journey - mainly in Greece at times
5,000 people were occupying carrots Jefe
even though its capacity was 1,400 so
the first thing that refugees knew when
they arrived at the camp is information
after the traumatic experience they may
not know which country they're in they
don't speak the language and they need
information in this critical time to
understand the process so I arrived here
I think it took us around in hours and
to see hearing someone speaking of the
same language with them don't be afraid
you are safe here listen to me and you
will go through these procedures you
will get your paper you will buy you 30
ticket what do they need to ensure that
they can be safe here while they stay
here but knowing that they would be
moving off the island very very shortly
and they needed the information
that would be key for them to make
informed decisions about their journey
to Europe another really important
aspect obviously for everyone is water
and so when this crisis first happened
what they would do is have people lined
up and handing out water but thankfully
it's close to a city and they were able
to actually cook the water up through
the city - right here throughout the
whole island the whole island is
suffering these problems so for this
reason we provided the capacity of 15
cubic meters of water also in case
there's a water cut we have our own
reservoir outside hi hello how you okay
say hi to a new friend can you let us
know your name are you weighing it so
what and they've been nice enough to let
us see that are at home and talk to us
about how what it's been like here at
the site and so what were you studying I
have English yeah yeah
what's that good thing they're both very
smart people water is not only essential
for hydration but a key component of the
wash program which stands for water
sanitation and hygiene poor sanitation
can lead to diarrhea dysentery cholera
outbreaks and other serious issues if
not contained you have to imagine 5,000
people without absolutely nothing so
we're talking about open defecation this
kind of situation the first response is
always chemical toilets that are placed
at least 50 metres away from the nearest
dwelling these are not sustainable and
only a temporary solution
the priority is then to build proper
toilet bathing and laundry facility then
the same 14 latrines and wasn't as you
can see everything was wind as basic as
possible yes to be able to deliver as
soon as possible and being able to
relieve the situation for Mia I accept
to everything here so I'm happy for for
but I am here I don't know we didn't but
you don't go and leave unfortunately I
don't complete - yeah
I saw it first of all and then you start
and I a my family in corner so we want
to go to the hall man and we want to
complete our our education so once
you've got the situation in control
you're able to monitor and to track them
then you can switch to a different
distribution method having like just
like the one you have like behind people
have a certain amount of items they can
like with six there with popular item
Canadians widening is this a partner
because it is used for everything yeah
you can reuse it for a maybe you can do
some dishes
so the me have things like toilet paper
Mauro large is likely so we think it
yeah nineteen years old works for
Disney's originated like that so mainly
what no one we know that so people come
here and you mention to have a card give
me a lot of the card work this is a man
that's the shelter this is it the
householder swaddles five miners one
kids food and Cara Pepe is delivered to
people's door in order to avoid
complications that occur when forcing
people to wait in law online and there
are several nutritionists who have
designed balanced meals which include
any dietary restriction next up is
shelter in the beginning refugees were
staying in tents but as a site is built
our refugee housing units or are accused
come into play
these were designed in Sweden in
partnership with IKEA plastic houses
that can be built in a day and help
against the weather and the elements as
carrot Effy's population became more
stable and permanent the final step was
to install ISO boxes of which there are
currently two hundred and fifty eight in
each Center the capacity recommended is
six people per Center but they'll be
focused on one particular family or
group of people who know each other so
for example this area is mostly are the
biggest speakers enough it can
little bit and then in the backside area
and in this area is more faster speakers
that are generally originally from
Afghanistan so these ISO boxes only been
here for a few months now and they're
basically just solid structures with not
a whole lot of the inside are really hot
yeah they can get really hot some of
them I think have AC units and
soft-pedal lease protection from the
elements in extreme cases of weather
okay good thank you
so a little youtube why did you start
making kite
well myself people on here but it looks
like we're gonna now see a muck around
the body they do so buckles - so how
long have you been here at Kara taipei
city most three months okay yeah no
civil and home oh seven a month we agree
yes yes it is so I know whether to go
there oh can I do it you blah yeah I'm
good electricity has been always a
really big challenge we needed to
respond with a renewable energies like
the solar panels and at the same time
with have fun all external burner carrot
Fe has the same electrical installation
of the common house for the entire camp
which is why renewable energy has become
so essential here behind us the
structure with the cupcakes on it these
are solar panels and these solar panels
will power these I subbox is to have one
light plus a USB port to charge your
phone and that's also really important
because the USB port and their phones
it's how they use flashlights at night
and obviously the light is important for
them to be able to see at night being
connected to Wi-Fi is also extremely
important to the refugees the news is
always changing the options are always
changing or even if the options say the
same the rumors around those options are
rampant so it's incredibly important for
refugees to be able to go online to be
able to check and see what the actual
facts are around their circumstances
here a really interesting camp because
it's so well put together there's so
much sort of thought an organization
that goes into it what you've been told
you know in other camps is not
necessarily the case
them have much wrapper conditions have a
harder time getting water or sewage or
electricity so amazing me they're being
met here and that's an interesting good
thing that these kids children we've
been staying here for eight to nine
months they need to have access to
education this is part of the human
right then the children right when you
learn Shakespeare yes if you have a
whole nother four six because it's hard
for it yeah I'm investigating another
like education program for like a
refugee and moving like displaced
populations the basic courses I will
enable them to join at a later stage a
normal electrical as the camp becomes
more established and more long-term
things like psychologists offices come
into play and doctors offices come into
play to help with not only trauma that
has happened from previous events but
chronic issues with health and mental
stability these are people who for the
most part have fled war they're seeking
sanctuary they really want nothing more
than to live a safe life they want their
kids to go to school they want to pursue
their dreams and they're stuck here and
they really have no true sense of what's
going to happen for them in the next few
months no sense at all if we want to go
on I think we have to wait the passport
to go to Alma then there we can we can
said that we don't know we don't want to
maybe come back and I probably I don't
know the little Oh
so we came here to talk about the actual
logistics of building a refugee camp but
you are just consistently meeting people
talking people and realizing the
humanity of it all and not only refugees
but people who work here who are so
passionate about the work they do and
care so much themselves into it I think
the issues is so complex like so often
people have these like opinions on it
they're like this is my opinion this is
the wage but it's so complex the levels
of
going on and the empathy that's required
for everyone to understand and to move
forward is really high it takes effort
to learn about these things the whole
thing is just being educated on the
issue but not projecting your feelings
as much and not projecting that anyone
can understand the entirety of this
crisis and it's just a really difficult
situation that a lot of people are put
in without wanting to be so being
compassionate being empathetic is the
most we can do and what people who are
suffering and so if something were to
happen in your country there is laws and
ways that you could leave and have
something like this to set up but you
would always want your freedom back
so far this side the way it's improved
and now the quality of life now existing
here it's amazing
you can't find another sites all over
Greece with the same living condition
but of course as a human being I would
like also these people to move somewhere
else
some get something better not a camp or
site or whatever you want to call it for
the IRC the ultimate would be to see a
world where there were no refugee sites
that you know where refugees could be
integrated into local communities where
refugees are integrated into urban
settings that they are living lives that
are full and self-sufficient and free oh
joy my girl she made such a girl yeah
yeah it does not anything sex again you
just wanna yeah yes yeah BAM intense in
Houma respond on en La Paz for mana
burden me hey pero no men no in Tania's
home besito
la sangre de madre do museu de la que
hablamos up sermon here Mustafa Nami
Saguna men get decision over there are
four locks for the top of the caucus
Minter which side the full module
of course probably um
[Music]
[Applause]